[Music]
jennifer's in champaign illinois hi
jennifer how are you
hello dave i'm blessed today how are you
better than i deserve how can i help
okay i'm calling on behalf of my
daughter to see what i can do to
possibly
help her out of the situation that she
has gotten herself
into she's a single mom
with two school-aged kids she has a good
job
where she makes about 32 dollars an hour
and has some excellent benefits with
that
unfortunately she has a lot of debt
and not a lot of assets in her case
what the situation did she get herself
into
she bought a house that was condemned
why with a gentleman because
she was with a significant other who
talked to her well
basically she went along with it drank
the kool-aid and went along with the
story
unfortunately her name is the only one
on the loan and it's a personal loan it
is not a house loan
so how much does she have on the
personal loan
um her personal loan is right around
twenty four thousand dollars is the
property in her name
it's in both their names where's goober
where'd he go
oh he's not paying on it at all i know
is he still around
oh yes okay yes i don't think we can
help her
well that was what i thought but my
question is
with her debt is there a better way for
her to refinance
that as opposed to this personal loan
that she has
now she needs to do sell the condition
at home as much as she can
as soon as she can and pay down the loan
as fast as she can
and probably evict goober
okay well she's no longer with goober i
thought you said he was still there
oh he's still in the city oh he's still
hanging around
but he got all he wanted out of this
okay now he's got half a house he wanted
out of this but this house is in
um it's most likely the city is going to
make them demolish it
yeah no they're not they're going to
make the new investor demolish it
because she's going to sell it this week
and goober's going to sign her i'm going
to threaten him within an inch of his
life
okay i like that yeah because he he's a
parasite
is what you've just described right
yeah he needs to sign and they need to
get rid of this house i hope your
daughter is not
further in debt when the smoke clears
but the house is not encumbered by a
mortgage she just has a personal loan
of 24 thousand dollars so if she gets 18
000 for the house
voila she's got an extra six thousand
dollars for having taken a trip with
goober
so it's not encumbered by a house loan
no you said it was a personal loan
yes it is it's probably not got a lien
on the house they probably didn't take a
lien on the property because it probably
isn't worth that much
any idea what they paid for it
it was fifteen thousand dollars they
paid for it and then she took out
a personal loan to do home improvements
on a house that would
you couldn't you could make it livable
maybe so she's
living in dollars no living with
us right now okay all right good there's
no way you could live in this it's a
horrible
horrible situation so again my question
was to see if there was anything that we
could do to advise her
i think let's cut let's cut bait let's
cut the losses as fast as we can
get him out of her life as fast as we
can as far as we can permanently and get
this property out of her life it's not
going to be anything but a money pit for
her
she needs to get rid of it and if she
ends up a little bit in the hole getting
rid of it so be it that's part of the
price she paid for this bad decision
i'm so sorry for her what a horrible
thing
so our last caller mom calling
grieving for her daughter who has
children
single mom she hooks up with a guy who's
a bad dude
he may not be intentionally bad dude
but he's stupid and he talks her into
getting on the stupid train with him
and together they buy a condemned house
for 15 000 and they put another 9 000 in
it and she has 24 000
and she already had 32 000 in debt and
she already was a single mom barely
making it living with her mom
i have done a whole lot of stupid things
in my life
and i have coached and sat with people
and cried with people and prayed with
people that have done a whole lot of
stupid things in our life
most money problems
are self-inflict
most of the time like
almost all the time that i have gotten
messed up in a money situation lost my
tail in
was because i was stupid
and you know when i'm the dumbest the
same time that poor girl was
i'm the dumbest when i'm desperate
right after i get desperate i get really
stupid
because when you get desperate you will
grab at things and try to do
things that you know in your mind are
not going to work
but somewhere deep down in your heart
you think you're going to win the lotto
so you buy the ticket
knowing you're not you think you're
going to beat the odds
you look at this guy standing in front
of your young woman and you know he's a
twerp
but you're so desperate that you try to
hook up with him anyway
he tries to talk you into buying a
freaking condemned house
and you know this is not going to work
but you're so desperate that you tried
anyway
and now we've got an extra tens of
thousands of dollars worth of problems
it's hurts so bad i'm so sorry
and some people don't like it that i
call some of these things that people do
stupid oh ramsay just calls you stupid
ramsay calls himself stupid so we're all
stupid we're all on
we've all bought a ticket a time or two
on the stupid train i'm not
saying anything that i haven't done or
i've done stupid with zeros on the end
so i'm not picking on any body or
shaming anybody
but i mean just be careful when you're
the most vulnerable when you're the most
desperate because that's the most time
you're gonna fall into the trap
when you're desperate for companionship
you'll overlook the fact that this guy
is just
mentally ill when you're desperate
to get out of your mother's basement you
overlook the fact that this real estate
deal is a
horrible idea desperate
always leads to stupid
high probability of stupid is following
desperate be careful folks